le roi lion ccim par sigma a tapé mambo
j'adore bombay je peux pleurer ariel
j'adore le génie un sale et oui c'est
bien les vieux baby mullan ja
physiquement c'est le plus facile belle
entrée puis intelligente je suis bon bah
j'ai les mêmes problèmes gastriques de
booba le clochard quoi taper la bête
alors quand j'étais tout petit j'étais
arrivé en retard à l'école et jamais
inventé une panne d'hélicoptères pour
rentrer de la campagne comme si je
rentrais de la compagnie capteurs
d'avoir fait croire que c'était sorti
avec une spice girls
quand imagine le truc ici elle est venue
on a bu un verre ces grands cheveux ni
com - ira tout le temps ça dépend des
moments de la journée
simple parce qu'en fait on est de faux
simple est derrière notre simple étude
se cachent d'autres intelligences on les
différentes formes et mfoumou respecter
m
la prof atchoum ya pas de remords mais
franchement fin avec les schtroumpfs du
âge qui dorment temps là où il s'appelle
normes heures travailleurs mangeurs
c'est pas tout à fait ça mais c'est à
peu près ça à la paix les clochards
j'adore la petite sirène
ariel et mulan roi lion 1 parce que je
n'ai vu avec mon fils qui étaient tout
petits étaient complètement cassé par le
tap a lyon ils meurent ici pour fait que
moi j'allais mourir a prêté à seymour
mary poppins g min min chez oh le plus
de larmes ces bandits c'est l'histoire
de la vie quoi de ces drames de ces
joies d'être le roi lion déjà que j'ai
pour être le bon filon félin bandits et
des bossas ma déprime c'est que il en
faut peu pour être heureux vraiment peu
pour être heureux il faut se satisfaire
du nécessaire ou libérés
le livret
et moi c'est moi c'est moi simba loi d
animal sauvage
[Musique]
je me sens et du cher je voudrais déjà
être roi
[Musique]
j'ai tendu